chuckle what are some workouts to
progress in becoming more relaxed in the
water I need to lower my heartrate okay
again this is a a good question it's
actually a little bit of a universal
question that's why again I like to take
questions that apply universally to
multiple things becoming comfortable in
the water is very important water makes
you better water makes you a better
person and I'll tell you I've said this
before and the SEAL Teams are one of the
things that makes us good in the SEAL
Teams we have to deal with water and
water as a pain in the ass ruins things
it floods things it stops thing it stops
guns from working it stops radios from
working it stops humans from working you
drown in it its water is very tough to
deal with it's a very harsh environment
especially the ocean water I used to say
that every time you go in the water it's
a real world Bob cause you can get
killed you can get killed in the ocean
you can get killed the ocean today if
you make the wrong moves so you
definitely need to be comfortable in the
water now first things first water will
kill you water will kill you you will
die if you make mistakes in the water
you will die so whoever is wrote this
question and whoever's gonna heed my
advice here note and be advised that
water will kill you so when you swim you
got to have a lifeguard and there's a
couple examples a guy in mind that when
I went through SEAL training with who
was a stud a complete stud he was the
honor man of my buds class and a great
guy I mean not just I mean it's cool to
be honor man it means you're good
athlete but he this guy was also beyond
that was just a great guy extremely
motivated name is Keith Kimura and he
was practicing breath holds as he was in
uses you know after we went through SEAL
training and he would get gone to a SEAL
team and served and he'd come back to be
a seal instructor and he was practicing
breath holds during a
during an evolution for the students and
while all that was going on you know
they're doing stuff with the students
and he's down there practicing bread
fall on his own kind he was on his well
he was in the group but on his own if
that makes sense so there's a big
evolution going on and while this big
evolution going on he's kind of doing
his own thing right and he died he was
doing breath holds he stayed down there
he had a shallow-water blackout and he
he died and it was awful I mean what a
what an incredible incredible guy we
also had some seals 2015 that were in
Virginia Beach you know young studs
getting after a training super hard and
they both died in in the pool in
Virginia Beach and again you know these
are frog men these guys are pushing
themselves and you know trying to make
themselves better and they push that
envelope and that's what seals do and
they pushed it and they went over the
line and unfortunately they were
training together at the same time so
you gotta be safe you you got don't
train alone and don't train with someone
that's doing the same thing as you at
the same you can't do the same thing
together you know it's a real it's it's
a real simple rule two one up one down
so if it's your turn to Train I stay out
and then you do your evolutions and then
when you're done okay now it's my turn
to train you stay out and you watch me
it's one up one down that's the that has
to be the standard again people don't
don't play around with the water you
know I've had shallow water blackouts
and you just come and that's it you're
unconscious and if you if someone's not
there to drag you out you're gonna drown
you're gonna die that's it yeah and they
again it's sort of you can tell that
they're coming a little bit and you get
used to them but it's sort of like
getting choked out in jujitsu yeah you
know you've been choked out before right
yeah many times
yeah so you think you're gonna make it
yeah and and then you don't and you can
push it too that's the things especially
when you're training like when I'm
trying to get
like chokes and you wanna be if you have
some fight in you
you know you want to be able to fight
you know so you push it a lot of times
especially when you have experienced
push it a little bit and then sometimes
cuz you just gotta go you can feel the
backup coming but once you go right past
that point
you're you can't pop anymore you go out
you know jiu-jitsu safe cuz usually the
guy can feel you go out and he let you
go but bro in the water it's like it you
know what the event horizon is in a
black hole yeah that little there's a
line over that line you're done and
that's exactly what happens with your
consciousness you're you you you you can
see that line you're watching yeah okay
I'm gonna make it and then all the
sudden it's gone yeah you're over the
line you're in the black hole and that's
it so be very very careful when you're
doing this always have a swim buddy swim
with a lifeguard all that stuff now the
question back to the question beyond the
safety portion is how do you get more
comfortable in water you spend time in
the water
swim surf spearfishing snorkeling scuba
diving survival floating breath holds
treading water just that's how you get
comfortable in the waters by being in
the water give yourself a little
challenges swim with swim with t-shirts
in your hands swim with your clothes on
swim d jock while you know just all
those things to get to be in the water
and do things and swim and that's how
you get more comfortable in the water
and you'll rapidly increase your ability
to be in the water and handle yourself
in the water and you'll be much more
calm in the water and the reason I said
this is a universal question is because
it's the same thing with just about
everything else that you're gonna do
it's the same thing with swimming it's
the same thing with doing put you want
to get good at pull-ups do more pull-ups
you want to get better at public
speaking get up and start doing public
speaking same thing with shooting like
when people first start shooting and
they're all intimidated by firearms it's
because they're not used to them so
spend time shooting spend time around
guns you'll get used to the muzzle flash
you get used to the concussion of the
noise and you will be more comfortable
about it so that's what you need to do
in the water you spend more time in the
water and and you'll get better at it
you'll get more comfortable but again be
careful when you're doing it the water
the water will kill you hey what does D
Joc oh it's a term as far as I know it
comes from
from seal training where when you put
your scuba gear on
they call it jocking up so jock up and
your Garrett and then it wrap you in the
SEAL Teams it becomes it's it's a term
that means any type of getting your
clothes on getting your gear on getting
your clothes on getting dressed
put your jock strap on that's what it is
I don't know if that's where it comes
from I think you can but they used to
play you know they remember that like
little kids game hangman yeah where you
filling the letters well whenever the
class would make a mistake they would
put they'd have jock up written on the
board and they put one letter in and
then when you spelled out all of jock up
then they would make a new jock up
drills which are not fun but it's just
putting on stuff your gear
yes but the jock up drills involve
ridiculously stupid and hard calisthenic
workouts with your entire gear loadout
you know what bear-crawling is yeah yeah
so you to bear crawl with twin 72 tanks
on you know we bear crawl to the chow
hall I mean it's a mile easy I think I
think our instructors got in trouble for
making us bear crawl would ya did you
Nev a convention called it's a bro no
yeah yeah we had in football we had to
there was an incident in camp in
football at uh-1 time and where we're
supposed to be you know sleeping you
know
lights out whatever yeah and the a guy
who remained no names to Paolo this is
like when I was young I was like a
freshman to ball awesome one guy and he
um I I can say his name now cuz he
admitted it afterwards but before their
like we would had to keep his calm yeah
totally classified super getting
absolutely yeah but do you wonder what'd
he do okay so people were messing about
we're supposed to be in bed so security
comes or whatever and like
everyone hides some say we wasn't me I
wasn't doing it and someone threw a
sandwich at the security guard hit him
and it was this big incident the same
you know in and of itself throwing sound
security guard that's more funny than
anything but we're supposed to be in bed
you know our football team you can't do
that you know so it was like a who was
this if no one admits it everyone's
gonna get punished so of course everyone
gets punished we're doing bear crawls
across across the field non-stop mm-hmm
so he was like I can relate to the bear
crawl to the chow hall it wasn't like
okay bear crawl to here and then bear it
was like you're going all the way I
don't even know how many times we did it
one guy was like Krotz was crying so you
face up crying grown men crying I don't
like that guy nonetheless so yeah bear
call that's rough man bear crawls no
joke but I think jockeying up is because
you wear your jockstrap when you get in
the game like a jockstrap jock you know
maybe one of the old utt you guys that
listen to the podcast will contact me
and let me know where jock up came from
yeah that's my man I do anything that's
cause of jock gearing up gearing up jock
strap is like the manly you know I'm
telling not going down this road I'm
already down the road yeah I'm not gonna
agree with you I think you're wrong
there you go right